in this video I'll be introducing the
concept of the universal set and
complements so I want to begin by
talking about the universal set which is
commonly referred to as the universe now
the reason I use this fancy looking you
here is that I was defining the universe
which is to say the maximum boundaries
of my set my biggest set everything
outside of this blue circle here doesn't
exist I mean in terms of the sets
nothing exists I don't even exist
computers is just you don't exist
but everything within it does so that's
a very important key now if I don't
define this if I don't define my
Universal set then we just assume it to
be the real numbers so if I just erase
this then you know this will just be the
real numbers which is we've talked about
in previous videos so the other thing I
want to talk about is complements so if
I say if I'm looking for the complement
of B and I'll put a more formal
definition of if I'm looking for the
complement of B then it is everything
that is not within B so all the elements
not within B are gonna be part of the
complement so in this case it would look
like this if I just highlighted
everything it would be everything within
the universe still and then so that is
the complement of B it's all the
elements that are not in B so that's
that's quite a bit of quite a bit I mean
there you got 1 2 3 4 5 6 so since this
is the real numbers these little dots
here would represent all the numbers all
every single value rational irrational
that are not within B so if this is 1 in
2 or better yet how about this this is
the
rational numbers and these are the
integers so these would be everything
outside of this would be the irrational
numbers and the non integer values